OnOn retrouve Véronique prince,
MiMichel et Christian.
- - Bonsoir.
- - Depuis que Monsieur Legaulta
lilié la survie du français avec
lele rapatriement du pouvoir en
imimmigration Québec, on allait
poposer la question à Monsieur
TrTrudeau, et voici sa réponse.
- - La réalité, c'est
ququ'on travaille très bien
enen partenariat et depuis
lolongtemps avec le gouvernement
dudu Québec. Le Québec fixe
seses propres cibles au niveau
dede l'immigration. C'est sûr
ququ'un pays doit continuer
d'd'avoir un mot à dire sur
soson immigration, mais on est
trtrès contents de pouvoir
papartager cette responsabilité
dadansle cas du Québec, parce qe
lala protection du français
etet de l'immigration francophoe
esest importante pour nous.
- - Alors il dit qu'un pays
sosouverain garde le contrôle
d'd'une partie de l'immigration.
JeJe vous montre rapidement le
tatableau qu'on a préparé hier.
LeLe contrôle et au Québec avec
l'l'immigratation économique, ms
lele gouvernement fédéral avec e
reregroupe en familiale et les
réréfugiés a un rôle à jouer.
AlAlors, Véronique, s'était
atattendu et j'envie de vous
dedemander: qu'est-ce que va
rérépondre Monsieur Legault?
- - Il savait très bien que c'et
cece que Justin Trudeau allait
rérépondre il savait que ça allt
alalimenter davantage le débat
ququ'il a lancé parce qu'il faut
cocomprendre que ça fait un an
ququ'il y a des stratèges de son
bubureau qui ont été libéré pour
prpréparer la campagne électorae
mamais déjà ils avaient détermié
quque le sujet de la campagne qi
ététait le nationalisme, parce e
çaça génère des émotions et ça
fafait vibrer la petite corde, t
ququand on regararde les sondag,
esest-ce que les adversaires
popourraient être Justin Trudea?
PaParce que les conservateurs,
s's'ils sont élus, il y aurait s
enenjeux de ce côté, on qu'est-e
quque ça pourrait être le
gogouvernement fédéral pour donr
auaux raisons aux gens de suivre
lala campagne de voter parce que
sisi Monsieur Legault obtient ue
cecentaine de députés mais qu'iy
a a un taux de participation de5
% % aux élections, est-ce que
vrvraiment elle valait avoir un
mamandat fort?
JeJe pense qu'en ce moment on
esessaie de mousser.
- - en mai en place les
pepersonnages et le rôle de
chchacun.
MiMichel, la réponse de Monsieur
TrTrudeau était écrit dans le
ciciel.
- - Oui c'est l'entente du
ininternational que c'est le
CaCanada qui s'occupe des
réréfugiés.
C'C'est aussi quelque chose du
dodomaine humanitaire, qu'on
coconnaît l'immigration c'est
sosouvent une personne seule qui
ararrive et qui quelques années
plplus tard faites venir sa
fafamille et ses enfants et des
fofois la grand-maman.
DoDonc le gouvernement fédéral
veveut garder cela, mais dire
ququ'il y a un péril en la demee
sisi on n'a pas le contrôle de a
réréunification familiale, la
momoitié de cela ça sera des
enenfants qui iront à l'école
frfrançaise, je suis pas sûr que
dedevient la Louisiane à cause s
grgrand-maman.
- - Christian, sur sa déclaratin
dede Monsieur Legault en fin de
sesemaine et la réponse de
MoMonsieur Trudeau.
- - Je trouve que Monsieur Trudu
n'n'avait pas besoin de politisr
unun dossier aussi important por
lele Québec.
PaParler de la Louisiane ça a
pepermis à des commentateurs de
riridiculiser les propos de
MoMonsieur Legault.
IlIl y a un grave problème au
QuQuébec en matière d'immigratin
etet le Québec est une des
sosociétés au monde qui reçoit e
plplus d'immigrants, et pourtant
nonous présente comme une sociéé
fefermée.
LeLe problème c'est qu'on est
paparti d'un pays qui a un
mumulticulturalisme délirant, on
nonous dit que le Canada devrait
avavoir 100 millions d'habitants
etet ses Clarke pour le Québec e
memenaçant.
DaDans le tableau il manquait ds
chchiffres importants, on nous
rarappelait ce matin que ce
n'n'était pas identitaire, on ns
rarappelait qu'il y avait 70 000
imimmigrants qui étaient à titre
d'd'immigrants temporaires.
EtEt si on ajoute le chemin Roxm
onon nous dit qu'on va peindre 0
00000 immigrants cette année.
LaLa majorité sont en train
d'd'utiliser des voies débitéest
sasans parler des étudiants
dedes pays francophones qui
sesemblaient être bloqués.
JeJe trouve que Monsieur Legaul,
jeje regrette beaucoup qu'il est
popolitisé ce dossier parce que
leles analystes tournent autourt
didisque ça sera bon pour lui et
quque Justin Trudeau ne pouvait
quque répondre cela.
CiCinq dossiers majeurs et ce
n'n'est pas un problème
arartificiel, on est pris dans n
papays qui pourrait recevoir un
dedemi-million d'immigrants par
anannée et qui envisage avoir 10
mimillions de personnes.
C'C'est de cela que Monsieur
LeLegault devrait discuter avec
OtOttawa.
- - À la période des questions,a
a a rebondi, Mme Anglade Monsier
LeLegault.
DODOMINIQUE ANGLADE, cheffe de
l'l'opposition officielle, Québc
- - Le premier ministre,
cece qu'il fait, ce qu'il divise
leles Québécois. Il fait tout
popour avoir une chicane avec
OtOttawa. Puis ce que je reconns
ququand je regarde le premier
miministre puis qu'on regarde
cece qu'il fait, c'est vraiment
unun gouvernement qui est
enen train de mettre en place
unune gouvernance séparatiste.
- - On peut s'occuper d'économie
pupuis en même temps se préoccur
dede l'avenir du français
auau Québec. Puis, c'est là
ququ'on voit que le Parti libérl
a a de la difficulté à faire
dedeux choses en même temps.
- - La question que j'ai pour
lele premier ministre, c'est :
popourquoi il est allé parler
dede la survie du Québec et de
lala Louisiane, lorsqu'il parlat
dede pouvoir de réunification
dedes familles? Pourquoi il est
alallé faire ça?
- - Il y a une tendance,
etet si on fait rien,
àà long terme... Est-ce que
çaça prendra 25, 50, 60 ans,
ilil y a un risque effectivement
quque le Québec se retrouve dans
lala même situation que les auts
prprovinces canadiennes,
quque la Louisiane.
- - Donc, il a rappelé et répété
auaujourd'hui cette image de la
LoLouisiane.
0 0 en fait le débat sur
l'l'immigration, ça fait quand
mmême plusieurs mois, on les
fafaisait en 2008, alors c'est
cocomme s'ils veulent amener pls
loloin en faisant référence à la
LoLouisiane.
EsEst vraiment le Québec peut êe
cocomparés à la Louisiane?
EsEst-ce que vraiment Louisianea
étété provoqué par un problème
d'd'immigrants?
JeJe ne sais pas si les deux
sisituations sont comparables.
CeCe que j'ai remarqué parcece n
sasait que François Legault réui
soson pari, parce que c'est sûr
ququ'en ouvrant le compte
d'd'immigration avec le
gogouvernement fédéral, il prête
flflanc à des attaques Parti
lilibéral qui dit qu'il y a un
agagenda caché, alors que dans
l'l'cas qu'il y a quand même
bebeaucoup de ministres
féfédéralistes.
JeJe pense qu'il est prêt à jour
cece jeu parce que ses adversais
n'n'ont pas le vent dans les
vovoiles comme lui.
EtEt quand je dis qu'il a réussi
soson pari c'est que ça fait en
sosorte que pendant la période e
ququestions, pendant trois
sesemaines la question de
DoDominique Anglade était la
pépénurie de main-d'oeuvre
mamaintenant on parle
d'd'immigration.
- - On a l'impression, depuis
ququelques jours qu'il y en a qi
sosont nostalgiques, qui aimerat
rerevivre un épisode avec la
babarrière souverainiste et
féfédéraliste.
MmMme Anglade et d'autres ont dt
ququ'il exigeait cela d'Ottawa,
mamais que si Ottawa nordique n,
ilils feront quoi?
EsEst-ce que tout cela, comment
vovous voyez la suite des chose?
- - L'seul endroit où il y a des
gegens qui pensent sérieusement
quque Monsieur Legault est un
sosouverainiste caché et qu'un
jojour il rouvrira son manteau,
c'c'est dans la communauté
ananglophone qui est en trtraine
peperdre les appuis de la
cocommunauté anglophone, c'est
DoDominique Anglade.
AlAlors, le jour où Monsieur
LeLegault dira qu'il est
sosouverainiste, il n'y aura pls
lala CAQ.
MoMonsieur Legault a toujours eu
unun problème avec l'immigratio,
l'l'année dernière il ne savait
papas ça prenait combien de tems
avavant de devenir citoyen
cacanadien et l'année d'avant nn
plplus,
cece n'est pas quelqu'un qui est
hahabitué de parler des migratis
etet à être dans les communautés
imimmigrantes.
IlIl n'a pas fait beaucoup de
sosouper spaghetti dans la
cocommunauté italienne.
ChChaque fois qu'il parle
imimmigration il trouve un moyen
d'd'exagérer ou dire des choses
papas après.
- - Christian, vous disiez que
c'c'est important de parler
ououvertement des choix qu'on pt
fafaire au cours des prochaines
anannées en immigration.
AuAu Québec, le débat s'était
bebeaucoup 55, 70,
pepersonne ne propose de coupere
rorobinet complètement?
- - Je trouve cela désolant la
fafaçon dont ce dossier est vécu
MoMonsieur Legault n'a pas beson
dede cela pour se faire réélire
etet je pense qu'il a réussi son
papari de manière très
susuperficielle parce qu'on toue
àà quelque chose de très sérieu.
OnOn est pris dans un pays qui
pepeut recevoir 3 millions
d'd'habitants par année.
LaLa majorité des immigrants au
QuQuébec ont tendance à venir pr
dedes voies d'évitement.
LeLes chemin Roxham et de moinsn
momoins mineur
c'c'est de cela qu'il faut parlr
ilil faut moderniser les entents
enentre Québec et Ottawa
enen matière d'immigration.
PaParler avec Monsieur Trudeau
sasans le choke comment parler e
lala Louisiane.
L'L'tout le monde dit que c'est
riridicule histoire de la
LoLouisiane, mais il y a un vrai
prproblème.
- - J'allais être poli, j'allais
papas dire ça.
JeJe viens à l'UPAC, le position
didit que c'est la preuve qu'il
avavait organisée des fuites et
quque c'est une police politiqu,
ququ'il y avait des gardes clan.
- - Est-ce que l'UPAC est
unune police politique?
DODOMINIQUE ANGLADE, cheffe,
PaParti libéral du Québec
- - Bien, quand on est rendu
àà arrêter des gens le jour
d'd'un budget, quand on est renu
àà poser ce genre de gestes-là,
ququi ne sont pas anodins.
OuOui, je pense qu'on peut
rérépondre oui à la question.
MAMARTIN OUELLET, leader
paparlementaire du Parti québécs
- - Si vous me posez la question
sisi, à l'époque, c'était
unune police politique,
lala réponse c'est oui.
EtEt le fait qu'on a encore
dedes gens qui étaient là
àà l'époque qui sont là
prprésentement à l'UPAC
nonous indique... à croire que
ririen n'a changé.
MAMANON MASSÉ, députée, QS,
SaSainte-Marie - Saint-Jacques
- - Québec solidaire a toujours
étété critique sur la lenteur
dedes actions de l'UPAC.
CeCe qu'on voit aujourd'hui,
c'c'est que... il y avait à
l'l'intérieur... potentiellement
àà l'intérieur, des éléments
ququi faisaient que ça tardait.
- - Rapidement, est-ce que c'est
lala fin à proprement parler de
l'l'UPAC?
OnOn part du passé, mais c'est
ququand même le même corps
popoliciers?
- - Je verrai difficilement la
miministre Guilbault dissoudrai
l'l'UPAC.
C'C'est censé être indépendant u
popolitique.
GeGeneviève Guilbault a une pate
chchaude dans les mains, elle ne
popourrait pas dissoudre un cors
popoliciers comme cela.
- - surtout que le nouveau patrn
a a été élu aux deux tiers de
l'l'Assemblée nationale.
- - Le problème de l'UPAC c'est
quque quand on parle de l'UPAC n
enentend les casseroles qui
trtraînent et c'est fatiguant
paparce que ça conforte tous les
gegens qui ont des doutes L'UPA.
MoMonsieur Lafrenière faisait de
lala politique en toute évidenc.
CÇa ne partira pas donc est-ce
ququ'il pourra encore façon
trtravail à cause de toutes ces
cacasseroles qui traînent?
JeJe commence à penser que non e
dedemanderai convaincu du
cocontraire.
- - Je rappelle que ça fait
prpresque quatre ans
ququ'on enquête sur les fuites
àà l'UPAC.
OnOn dit qu'il n'y a pas 1 milln
dede personnes travailler là-ba,
cocomment ça peut être si
cocompliqué
d'd'arriver à une conclusion?
LeLes gens en perdent leur lati.
- - On a sali beaucoup de
réréputation.
JeJe pense qu'il y a pu beaucoup
dede mondes qui font confiance à
l'l'UPAC, je ne sais pas si on
pepeut dissoudre l'organisation,
mamais j'aimerais la dissoudre.
SoSon mandat était de rétablir a
coconfiance dans les états
pupublics, j'ai quasiment plus e
coconfiance envers un bandit qui
fafait son travail de bandit pae
quque au moins il est authentiqe
ilils n'ont pas respecté leur
seserment d'office, comment
vovoulez-vous qu'on croit en ce
grgroupe?
JeJe souhaite que les nouveaux
fafassent un coup d'éclat parce
quque sinon quand je parle de
l'l'UPAC je ne peux plus lire ls
ararticles.
- - Vous devait lire les articl.
- - Oui je vais les lire.
GEGENEVIÈVE GUILBAULT, ministre
dede la Sécurité publique, Québc
- - C'est pas des choses qui
sese font du jour au lendemain,
ceces changements-là
ororganisationnels importants.
MoMonsieur le commissaire,
onon l'a nommé il y a deux...
unun an et demi, deux ans.
DoDonc, il est en fonction.
AlAlors, on laisse la chance,
mamais c'est sûr que, là,
àà partir du moment où nous,
onon leur a donné tous les outi,
lélégislatifs, réglementaires et
quque l'on a nommé un nouveau
cocommissaire, donc là c'est à x
dede livrer la marchandise et
dede faire le travail qu'ils ont
àà faire. On a confiance.
- - Vivement une enquête bien
bobouclée avec des accusations i
vovont tenir.
- - Il y avait juste une phrasee
trtrop dans ce qu'elle a dit c't
::
j'j'ai confiance je ne pense pas
ququ'ils ont confiance je ne pee
papas qu'ils sont en train
d'd'attendre les élections avant
dede voir le travail qu'il doit
fafaire.
IlIl y a pas grand monde qui
crcroit.
- - Pourquoi on dissout pas
l'l'UPAC?
PePersonne ne croit à la
mamaintenant.
- - est-ce qu'on va savoir les
fufuites un jour, c'est enquêteu
BEBEI, est-ce qu'on va y abouti?
- - On se pose la question et je
pepense qu'on laisse jusqu'en 24
paparce qu'ils ont besoin de 300
popour faire leur travail, maisa
pepeut passer vite.
- - Merci beaucoup à v